hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to the homeroom live stream
actually i think this is the first of
the year hopefully everyone had a good
new years considering the circumstances
and is enjoying 2021 given the
circumstances we have a very exciting
show today uh i think someone who needs
really no introduction uh but
melinda gates co-chair of the bill and
melinda gates foundation and author of
moment of lift how empowering women
changes the world so start thinking of
questions that you could put in on
youtube and facebook we'll try to get to
as many of those questions as possible
but before we jump into that
conversation i will give my standard
announcements a reminder that khan
academy we are a not-for-profit
organization that's funded through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about going to khan
academy.org slash donate and donations
at all levels really make a huge
difference i also want to make a shout
out to several organizations that
stepped up when they realized that the
world was depending on khan academy even
more during kovid so special thanks to
bank of america att google.org novartis
fastly and general motors but we
continue to need more help so anything
you can do is very much appreciated and
last but not least want to remind
everyone that you can get a version of
this live stream in podcast form
wherever you get your podcast at
homeroom with sal the podcast
with that i'm so excited uh to introduce
melinda gates author of moment of lift
how empowering women changes the world
and co-chair of the bill and melinda
gates foundation
melinda great to see you
hi sal thanks for having me
well there's so much that i i i could
talk about and you cover a lot of this
in your book and there's a lot of work
that you've done beyond the book maybe a
good place to start would be with the
book
why did you decide that now is a good
time to write a book and what what are
your hopes for it
well i wrote this book and introduced it
in 2019
and
now we're coming out just now with the
paperback and i wrote it at the time
because i had been lucky enough to
travel the world because of the
foundation and i'd met so many women
who had really animated my life and
called me to action and i felt if i
could tell their stories it might call
the world to action and when i wrote
this book i think we as a community
thought we were on our way towards
gender equality and now here we are in
the middle of a pandemic in early 2021
and women have really been set back in
the united states and all over the globe
so we have a lot more work ahead of us
and what's been surprising you know when
i when i saw the book and i started
reading it i expected to hear a lot of
the stories of your travels the work
that y'all have been doing with the
foundation and there's definitely that
but what's been really interesting it's
also a very personal book where you kind
of thread in your own experience trying
to balance the different
pulls on your time from
trying to be a great mother trying to
have a great career at the same time and
kind of relating that to you know a
general theme of of women around the
world have all of these things that
they're trying to balance
yes i thought it was important to
include my personal story i mean to
begin with you know i do live a a life
of extreme privilege now but growing up
i grew up in a very middle-class family
in the united states and i think no
matter whether you're in a low-income
country middle-income or high-income
women face a lot in their lives that we
just don't talk about and i thought it
was important to talk about my own
journey
and my own struggles with balancing
being a mom which i absolutely wanted to
be an am
and a working woman and i tried to then
highlight how that also is similar for
so many women around the globe who don't
even have the resources that i have to
to get some extra support and help
so i want to go and talk to you both of
those and i'm sure there'll be a lot of
questions of that but first when we're
talking about helping women around the
world and obviously there's the
pre-coveted context in which you wrote
the book and then what you're able to
see both in the broader kind of you
could say industrializing world and in
the in the industrialized world what
kovitz stresses are putting on what what
do you see as you know if if you want
people to walk away
with the the handful of things that are
the real challenges facing women that we
really have to address what are they to
you
they are to me the barriers that hold
women back
in society that we so often don't talk
about harassment and abuse whether at
home or in the workplace
the other big barrier quite frankly is
this child care work this unpaid labor
that women do in their homes every
single day no matter where you are in
the world women do more unpaid work than
their husband or their spouse does and
that keeps them often from being fully
in the workforce and being fully present
and then there are many things we can do
to accelerate women in key key
industries make sure we get money in
their hands accelerate them in finance
accelerate them in the tech sector in
the united states accelerate them in
policy-making and political positions
because until you have women with a seat
at the table using their full voice and
decision-making authority we will never
have sound policies that benefit all of
society and those are imperatives for us
if we're going to really move forward as
a world
you know there's a lot in that you know
there's a fairness argument which is a
very strong one there's the argument you
just made which is this argument around
you you really need a diversity of
viewpoints around the decision-making
table especially if it's going to affect
people of different
viewpoints
but you know in your book you're
referred to and this definitely struck a
chord with me you talk about the study
in bangladesh which is where my family
originally comes from were they able to
actually to some degree run an
experiment where women were more in the
driver's seat of things like family
planning and and what that led to it
didn't just lead to better outcomes for
those women if you could talk a little
bit about that because i think that's
that's a very a super a poignant example
for for why it's so important to invest
in women
yeah thank you for that question sal
because
i think so often we don't talk about uh
family planning or contraceptives and
yet when you look in the united states
what has allowed women to go to college
and to get a degree and to work in the
workforce it's being able to decide
when
whether and how often to have children
so in bangladesh as you reference in the
1970s the longest global health study
that's ever been run were two different
sets of villages where one set had full
ass access to contraceptives women were
educated about their bodies all types of
methods of contraceptives and then they
used them and other villages that didn't
have access and what they found over
this long study was that in the villages
where contraceptives were readily
available and used the families were
healthier the children were healthier
the children were better educated
and the families overall were wealthier
and that's because the moms and dads
could space the births of their children
and feed and educate each one of them
and start down that path to prosperity
before they chose to have another child
and that it makes a profound difference
in terms of unlocking the cycle of
poverty for a woman and for her family
now you talk about that i mean when you
point it out it's something we we so
take for granted you mentioned in the
book how you were able to essentially
plan things out it made me reflect on my
wife and my journey where you know my
wife also you know she's more educated
than i am she went to med school and
that for our first child we kind of said
okay there's that year right after
residency before you start okay let's
have our first child then and and that
ability which we take for granted is not
something that's commonplace for most of
human history and unfortunately a lot
part of the world is still not expected
and so it's it's really when you're able
to space it out the family can have
resources they can invest in their
children uh and then obviously i can
imagine that has follow-on effects are
there other you know it seems like
that's one of the top things just the
ability to have control and uh be able
to space things out and make sure that
the resources are there other
big things that you think
folks should know about uh and you know
folks being everyone listening people in
government people in the philanthropic
sector that are high leverage points for
empowering not just women but because
you're empowering them the communities
that they're they're part of
well certainly two things i would say
educating a girl when a girl has access
to school into a good education she
makes completely different decisions
about her life
and when she has access to those new
ideas and that new thinking
she also delays usually when she gets
married and when she has children that
again has a profound effect on a
community not just at a community level
but at a regional level and at a country
level and it's why finally in the last
10 years
so many presidents and prime ministers
actually finally show up at the un
and talk about girls education getting
girls into school and keeping them all
the way through at least secondary
school
so that is a really important factor is
girls education just like boys and the
other one is getting economic means in a
woman's hand so all over the world one
of the things that we now have of course
are phones and even if you don't have a
smartphone but you have access to an old
plastic phone
there are governments all over the world
india bangladesh many others tanzania
kenya where they're making sure that
women and men can save a dollar a day
two dollars a day on their phone so they
actually have a bank account
so that when the school fees come due
for the child or there's a health shock
in the family or they need to purchase
food the woman has money of her own that
is not her husband's money and that is
vitally important because it empowers
her in the family and she is often the
one who decides who's gonna eat first
second and third or who's gonna go to
the medical facility or who's who's
gonna help pay for the tuition when it
comes due at the school so a woman when
she has money in her hands she can get
out of an abusive situation she can
invest in a small business she can make
different decisions for herself and her
children
money is power and it makes a difference
for women's own power and influence
it makes a ton of sense you know at
least a natural question when i read
some of the stats the studies on these
various dimensions
it seems like a no-brainer that more of
the world should be focused on this
should be investing i know there's been
a lot of progress over the last several
decades but it also makes me wonder why
weren't people already doing that you
know the role of why haven't governments
uh you know why has there had to be such
an emphasis on the philanthropic sector
and then maybe take the other side you
know you in the book mentioned when you
first met hans rusling famous you know
data visualizer how he was skeptical you
know i think he said something like you
know american billionaires are going to
mess things up um what do you and you
hear that more and more in the public
narrative of people saying well
philanthropy sounds good but we're not
so sure or maybe this is too much power
in the hands of a few people
where do you where do you see that
balance where's the role of philanthropy
and and what's your sense of uh you know
how how you make people realize that
there's actually a lot of value here
so
let me start with the second question
which is philanthropy's role i think
philanthropy
does its best when it understands that
it is part of an ecosystem what you need
is philanthropy
government
private sector that is businesses
civil society all working together to
benefit the world and society
what can philan philanthropic money do
that some of the others can't they can
take risks where there is no market so a
business won't enter it or where the
government doesn't want to take the risk
with the citizens money it can try new
things it can further new ideas and if
those things prove out then it's up to
government to fund them and to spread
those ideas
so to your question though the earlier
one was why was it a decade ago when you
know 15 years ago i'd happen to be at
the un or other places with other global
leaders no one talked about girls first
of all girls were not on the agenda
women were only on the agenda when it
came to their maternal health
prime ministers and presidents didn't
talk about women and girls other than
that
well why is that it's because we run in
a society where males
run the top of society they run the
political bodies they run quite often
the social media platforms they run the
newspapers and so
you have to make sure that you actually
make extra investments to help women
rise up into those positions of power
because if you don't have a diverse
slate of people at the table that is in
our own country people of color
women and men you then don't get a
diverse representation of society and so
you make policy government policy based
on what you know but if that comes from
say a group of just white men they don't
see the full
view of society that a woman or a person
of color with their lived experience
would have seen and thus you don't build
into society the places that will unlock
opportunities for women and people of
color and that's why i am such a big
proponent of making sure we create
pathways for women into the key key
industries such as politics or finance
or tech because of how pervasive and how
much those areas run our society and our
globe
and i couldn't agree more and you know
the question i asked
you know i i i i obviously you know in
full disclosure many folks know
you know your foundation has been you
know one of kind of the founding
sponsors of khan academy so obviously i
have some biases here that i should have
a full disclaimer for but khan academy
would not exist without the
philanthropic sector and it absolutely
you know even when my friends were
skeptical why does khan academy even
exist shouldn't it be for-profit or
shouldn't be government it's exactly in
that zone
where it needs to move fast and innovate
but it needs to operate on values that
maybe market forces which i'm normally a
big fan of might not lead to the
outcomes we want and that's just a small
example but some of the work that y'all
have been doing
with malaria with uh with with polio
with you know diarrhea some of these
things that shouldn't be killing anyone
for the last several decades were
killing thousands or in some cases
millions of people i mean
i mean both you and bill i think are
very
humble about how many million literally
millions of lives you saved and arguably
it should be part of government but um
without the philanthropic sector there i
don't think you know these aren't vanity
projects i don't think any of that would
have would have happened um you know one
question a lot of questions coming in on
on on social media i'll get to some of
them i've been using my privilege to
take all my questions but this question
it's related to that last point it's
from youtube from chillax
why what do you think you have achieved
by working and collaborating with women
in different countries and you know i do
wonder that you know you and bill you go
on a lot of these trips you go on a lot
of trips you visit villages you're
really in places that many of us have
never been to you know my family's from
bangladesh i think you've gone into more
of the real rural villages of bangladesh
than i or many of my many members of my
family have ever been to
what do you learn from those trips that
you might not have appreciated before
well i think it's fundamental to to
travel and to listen and to learn
because i think you know we could come
in with our western point of view of oh
you need this for your child or this is
the way to do things because we do it
that way in the u.s or europe when in
fact you listen to the locals they have
very good reasons for doing what they do
and they have seen more death and
disability than we have they can tell
you what might work or what the barriers
are that hold them back you can come in
for instance with the very best vaccine
or new tool let's say for malaria but if
the village elder who makes the decision
won't let that tool be taken up it's
going to go nowhere
and so for women what i have learned is
you need to go in sit down with them in
their homes and where they gather in the
village market or on a local mat talk
with them and the men
eventually let the men wander away back
to the fields or to their business and
then you hear the truth
of women's lives and you hear what
they're up against what lengths they
will go to
how they do take their meager means and
feed their children and you learn that
women are incredibly resilient and so
one of the things i've been fortunate
enough to be involved in or help lead is
this effort on family planning because
so many women have told me i've heard of
those tools we used to have them in my
village i don't have them now and i have
six children i cannot have a seventh i
cannot feed these children
and so i've helped lead this family
planning effort because there are 200
million women asking us for
contraceptives and we need to
educate women about contraceptives in
their bodies if they don't know about
them and if they do make sure they have
access to them so they can voluntarily
decide
if they want to use them and if and when
to have children
and where do you think this is going i
mean you've talked about a lot of the
good work that's already happened but it
also is kind of painting a picture
there's a lot of important work that
needs to be done what do you see for
yourself or i would say for the broader
sector
what needs to be the priorities for the
next five or ten years and what is an
outcome we can be hopeful about in ten
years and and maybe one that we should
be afraid of if we don't take action
yes well i will have to be frank that
this covet 19 pandemic has set us back
enormously in global health and global
development you know where poverty was
on the decline we're now seeing poverty
on the rise where
we were making huge inroads on
contraceptives for instance they're now
going to be 15 million
unintended pregnancies this year alone
we estimate because of the lack of
contraceptives
so the global health community will have
a lot of building back to do to make
sure that vaccination rates stay up to
make sure children are fed and kept
alive
but some of the things we can be hopeful
about i think do come from these new
tools the fact that so many people
around the world have a cell phone in
their hands you know information is
power money is power
we can give them life-saving information
on their phone we can hook start to hook
them up in their local community with
telemedicine
especially if the health services just
aren't there aren't functioning well
which is true in many countries around
the world and so i think these new
digital tools give us opportunities as
long as we get them out equitably into
women's hands we teach women about the
internet and we make sure that they have
access and so it means we have to do
special programming just for women so
that they do actually get these new
tools or if there's a new seed available
that's drought resistant or pest
resistant against climate change we have
to go the extra mile to not just get it
in the hands of men but to get it in the
hands of women too so they can get a
bigger yield and get more income off
their farm because most women in the
world their work is in the informal
sector and they're farmers
and and i mean you touched on that in
that last statement you know what do you
see as the role obviously there's a role
for policymakers as a role for
philanthropy
there's a huge role for women obviously
in this what do you see is how do we
change the the culture or what's going
on in the men's minds and you know i'm
curious about a lot of places we've been
talking about where even things like
family planning you can't take for
granted uh but then after that i have a
few questions about you know how do we
do it in a lot of our lives as well
well i think to change culture you
really have to start where people are
and you have to listen to them about why
they have certain beliefs why they do
things the way they do them and only
over time with a lot of trust and
discussion can you start to introduce
new ideas and then people have to decide
for themselves do they want to take up
those new ideas yes you can push down
with top-down policy
for instance a good child marriage law
but communities have to accept that and
decide they're not going to do child
marriage again even in the united states
things like that used to be acceptable
before in my mom's generation we don't
expect we don't say those are the norms
today and so
we spread things and ideas through our
networks and then we influence one
another so for instance today you'd be
pretty hard-pressed to find too many
women smoking during pregnancy and yet
when jackie kennedy was the first lady
of the united states there's pictures of
her smoking well we became to learn that
is not good for babies or moms and but
those ideas there had to be good policy
but we had to have good ideas spread
that's how you spread new ideas in all
kinds of communities about issues for
women about breaking down men's thinking
about what women's roles can or should
be and even for us about what what ideas
we have about people of color in our own
country or indigenous people that's how
you change hearts and minds and it takes
time but it can be done
no and on that you know actually you've
touched on this in your own personal
life and actually i wanted some help
with with mine as well um
is you know you talk about this notion
which is absolutely true when we started
there that
in it whether we're talking about a
village in bangladesh or we're talking
about you know a two-income professional
family in seattle or silicon valley
some of this issue of you know women are
disproportionately taking doing a lot of
uh what has to happen in the house and
at home even when someone hypothetically
is a rheumatologist my wife's a
rheumatologist and you know my my
question is
and it's true and aren't my wife's
rheumatologist i obviously you know
spend my time working on khan academy
you know in theory i would love to to
for for there not to be this bias or
this uneven playing field but my wife
you know i we
we we ever argue i hear some families
argue about things like that
but but uh you know how much who does
what you know one thing i've thought
about do we just have unrealistic
expectations on both men and women that
essentially you know we want to be super
parents which could take 90 of your time
we want to be super workers which take
90 percent of our time and so if you
have two people
each three jobs that take 90 you're
trying to have you know 270 percent with
only 200 percent of time i'm curious how
you and and bill have navigated that
well i think in all of our homes we have
to look at who does what and we have to
say what are our values and what do we
want as a family and a society and i
think sometimes in the united states
we've gotten it a bit wrong where we
value you know work so much as opposed
to saying wait a minute in our homes we
all know we care about our families but
how do we balance society to make sure
there are good child care options out
there a good child care infrastructure
how do we make sure in our homes we have
the tough conversations about why do we
both men and women myself included have
gender normative ideas about who takes
out the garbage or who does the dishes
or who gets to go to their computer
first after dinner versus helping the
kids with homework we have to actually
look at all those tasks and say how do
we redistribute them and are there times
in each of our careers where maybe the
woman's career goes first for a while
and the man helps take care of the kids
a bit more at home and maybe then
there's a time where his career goes
forward and she takes care of the kids
more at home there are ways to blend and
balance this
but we do need better policy making in
the united states we need a paid
family medical leave policy we're the
only industrialized nation that doesn't
have one only 20 percent of our workers
get maternity leave that's that's insane
and so we need to have good policy and
we need to have honest conversations in
our homes if we're going to change
things
no i couldn't agree more and i could
talk for hours about this because i
think it's a fascinating subject
actually you know but whether it's in
the village or or in the city you know
the time we have left melinda any you
know parting thoughts and i actually
said you know especially to those who've
been watching we have students watching
we have parents we have people of all
ages uh but you know i also think about
it especially to the men you know not to
even view some of these things we call
them chores because you know there might
be chores at home but like to actually
to your point embrace some of these
things some of my best moments that i'll
never
regret in my life are when i am able to
help with you know uh give my kids a
bath they're a little older now so
that'd be awkward but when i was able to
give them a bath or or or or or clean
the house or whatever else um you know
what what messages would you want
everyone to take away both from your
book or just in general
i would say you know we need to look at
all of our norms in society whether i've
met people in you know a remote village
in senegal i've had men tell me like who
have taken on more chores or made some
changes normative changes in their
family um and and i'll eventually get
them alone i'll say well why did you do
that and they said because
that work is hard that my wife was doing
my wife was tired
when she's happier i'm happier and my
whole family is happier
and you know you asked we kind of have a
saying happy wife happy life i think
it's true if men and women are happier
in their homes our children are happier
and more balanced and we can go out and
do what we want to do so what i want to
say to people is it's possible we just
have to really re-look at things and
decide what is it that we want and what
i know
is that society is going to be better
off when we have women taking their
equal place to men not just in their
homes but at all places that decisions
are made and we all need to work towards
equality in the united states we're 208
years away from equality we sometimes
think oh we're 50 or 60 no we're 208
years away so we got we have to make
these decisions in our home if they're
going to have ripple effects in our
community and in our world and i know
it's possible
you you sounds like you're doing it and
thinking about it in your own home sal
and that's fabulous
no it's it's a we talk about it a lot so
so it's a real thing but you know it's
inspiring and it's good to know that you
know in some ways it's comforting to
know that that you and bill deal with
some of the same problems
that we're trying to some of the same
tensions but you know i could talk for
hours about this uh and your book which
is incredible i really encourage people
to take a look it's out in paperback
today uh where uh you know it talks
about i mean just a lot of really
interesting things i think everyone
needs to be informed about men and women
melinda thank you so much thank you so
much for the years of support uh for
what we're doing at khan academy and
frankly changing the lives of millions
around the world and setting an example
with things like the giving pledge of
kind of i think a new generation a new
type of philanthropy that i think is
changing the world so thank you so much
well thanks for having me on your
homeroom i wish you'd been in my
homeroom when i was growing up
all the best to you
see you thank you so much
well thanks everyone for joining you
know that was a wonderful conversation
as you could imagine i we could have we
could have spoken for for hours more uh
so so much so much in that uh but i
really do encourage y'all to take a look
at moment of lift uh there's you know i
was telling melinda before we went on
there's a lot that i expected to see
that i found very insightful about how
do you affect global health and empower
women but there's a lot of really i
would say almost intangible and very
personal stories about melinda and her
journeys and her struggles which i think
uh you know i i found a lot in that as
well so definitely take a look at that
uh uh also uh let you all know we're
gonna have another homeroom live stream
tomorrow
with jennifer dudna who is a 2020 nobel
prize in chemistry winner so we're going
to geek out hard tomorrow in chemistry
so encourage you all to come and
actually if you want do a little bit of
research ahead of time if you need a
little background knowledge i know a
good website called khan academy to make
sure your your chemistry is boned up to
be able to talk with a nobel prize
winner so look forward to that and i'll
see everyone uh tomorrow
you